what did Queen Victoria Charles Darwin
and Albert Einstein have in common they
all married their first cousins you
think Darwin of all people would know
better after all mating with a close
relative passes on bad genes that leads
to deadly genetic mutations right today
marrying your first cousin is illegal in
24 US states but for most of Western
history people had to marry whoever
lived nearby which oftentimes meant
marrying within the extended family in
fact between 1650 and 1850 the average
married couple was fourth cousins so
they had the same great-great-great
grandparents
genetically speaking that means they
shared 0.2% of their DNA not much when
you compare it to third second and
especially first cousins and the more
DNA you share the greater chance your
offspring will have a genetic disease
like cystic fibrosis or sickle cell
anemia but here's the thing you don't
have to be sick in order to give your
child a genetic disease take cystic
fibrosis it's caused by a defect in the
CFTR gene but you need two copies of the
defective gene to actually get the
disease so if you only have one
defective copy you are unaffected
instead you are what's called a carrier
now if one carrier mates with a non
carrier there's no risk of the kids
getting sick but when both parents carry
a defective copy of CFTR then the kids
have a 25% chance of inheriting two
copies of the gene and having the
disease so to see how dangerous it is to
marry your first cousin we need to
calculate the chances that two first
cousins both carry a copy of the same
genetic disease
since they share a set of grandparents
we'll start there now it becomes a game
of what-ifs what if both grandparents
are carriers versus just one one if one
of their children is a carrier versus
none at all and what if those children
marry other carriers or not it can get
very complicated very quickly but
scientists have crunched the numbers and
it turns out the risk that the cousins
have a kid who inherits a genetic
disease is four to seven percent for the
general population it's three to four
percent so not a big deal right here's
the catch that's the odds for one
genetic disease but there are thousands
that could be hiding in your family tree
plus if your kids also marry their first
cousins and their kids marry their first
cousins it's a recipe for disaster
because instead of introducing new
potentially helpful genes into the
family gene pool you're recycling the
old and possibly dangerous ones take
Emperor Ferdinand the first of Austria
his parents were first cousins twice
over and when he was born he wasn't
especially healthy so as far as marrying
your cousin is concerned you shouldn't
make it a family tradition what
interesting things have you found out in
your family tree let us know in the
comments
[Music]